hey everyone how you doing this morning
very interactive crap alright so I just
it's my first time with two microphones
and four screens as Todd had said I'm
gonna make this conversational and
practical as possible for as many of you
this is a talk where that I wish people
had given to me when I started doing
social science with Python and R and
other languages that really allowed us
allowed me to get out of the box and
collect new data to inform the social
science research that we do with the
Urban Institute which I'll describe
recent soon but essentially this came
about because when we have new hires at
urban and we're teaching them about you
know the possibilities of how you can
collect data from the web often they see
it as this great new tool that they can
use to do anything with that's really
exciting and I do want them to see it
that way because in in my field at least
we are still at the beginning of taking
advantage of some of the new tools
offered that you guys probably already
know of in data science that Python or
other these programming languages allow
you know to give you an idea a lot of
our researchers a lot of our staff at a
research organization work with
programming languages like Stata and SAS
that are like these traditional
statistical programming packages that
allow you to work with this rectangular
data set and that's about it and so we
sort of want them to be excited about
these new tools on the other hand
there's a lot that they can do that will
you know get them into both legal
trouble could block our organization
from having access to certain sites or
services and just a lot of trouble that
they can get in personally that I want
them to avoid so I made a lot of
mistakes in web scraping I've gotten in
a lot of trouble both you see of
receiving legal notices being threatened
receiving nasty emails having to talk
with lawyers and so to the extent that
you manage teams or you are part of a
team that's taking advantage of web
scraping these are some practical tips
that I have that I really like wish that
I had knew I had known seven or eight
years ago and I sort of started down
this road and I hope that they're useful
for you and if you have any questions
feel free
interrupts throughout or we can take
them at the end so the flow this talk is
going to be am and tell you a little bit
about the Urban Institute because we're
a little bit different than many of the
other organizations presenting here so
the power of web scraping and how they
sort of talk about it a turbine in
general what it can do and what it can
offer an organization some example
projects that we've used web scraping
with just to give you a flavor for how
we use it some tools and tips for web
scraping responsibly and doing it well
some of these you may may not surprise
you others I've you had data scientists
who were working for years and said oh
man I wish I known that trick that's
that's pretty neat organizational policy
so we have set we have set in stone or
not in stone but we have set in box
document the organizational policy for
web scraping and the rules and
checklists that people need to fill out
just to make sure that they're following
these these best practices and if it's
helpful for you I'm going to show you it
walking through a little bit of our best
practices from maybe they'll be useful
for you or your organization and then
give you a little bit of my contact
information stay in touch ask questions
learn more cetera so about the Urban
Institute as I mentioned we do social
and economic policy research we're about
a five hundred person organization or a
non-profit in DC and we have lots of
different research centers doing work
for both the federal government and for
private foundations on contract so we
answer research questions that the
federal government wants to answer there
private foundations want us to answer
about communities about social policy we
have ten or eleven centers now I think
it's 11 we just added our Education
Policy Center last week on education
health housing criminal justice all
these different policy issues so I work
daily with you know criminologist
economics phd's tax experts people like
that who are working to inform and as we
call it elevate the debate right so
inject some you know for state local and
federal policymakers inject some
evidence into decision making and so
data science at urban is a relatively
recent addition we've only been around
for about four years and this came about
because of all these new tools and
methodologies that are now available to
help to inform social science that
social sciences just don't know or
aren't taking a
Vantage of so you know you'll be amazed
to know that you know Stata and SAS
which of these statistical packages are
still the primary programming languages
taught in these social science programs
and how do I know that my background is
in both economics and public policy I am
NOT school trained data scientist I
started about eight years ago learning
Python R on my own and making all these
mistakes on my own as I just told you
and so you know in these programs it's
sort of an afterthought how you how you
actually do the data analysis itself we
think a lot about you know economic
theory how that applies in practice
doing some basic data analysis on clean
the data sets which is not the reality
and 90% of these situations and then you
know producing results but no one's
really trained in how to do that so this
data science concept is new we're a team
of about eight right now we've doubled
in the past year and a half in size and
we are supporting all of those research
centers across the Urban Institute so we
are bringing new methodologies to social
science leveraging new architectures
like Todd was talking about you know an
AWS using spark using new bigger data
systems on demand elastic instances for
researchers but also introducing them to
machine learning into web scraping it's
a natural language processing and how
they can use that to analyze text data
to gather new data from the internet
right to inform public policy and so
that's that's my role with urban is to
sort of be this you know gatekeeper into
this exciting data science world that
you all are probably already familiar
with and so that's where my talk is
really gonna start here where I am
marked it as novice and so I just want
to get a little bit of a sense of the
room so I can skip slides if necessary
so how many you guys have been in data
science or programmed in Python or are
any of the similar languages for the
last like two or three years five plus
years keep your hands up okay got it so
we have a few more senior people in the
room and some people have been doing it
for for for a couple of three years
that's that's great so so I won't go
over a lot about you know what is web
scraping I think you guys are pretty
familiar with it this is the definition
I came up with and I then I googled it
and found you know three definitions
that were really similar to mine so I
think this is generally what people
would call web scraping sort of
automating this processing and
collection of data from the
right but why do you web scrape you know
it's in one way one thing we like to use
it for and especially in social science
is to gather new insights about data
that we may not be able to access
otherwise so if there are data on my
first web scraping project way back when
was trying to figure out the quality
scores for DC restaurants right and DC
has this great site that lists in like
7,000 links and they have in each link
you can click on it and you get like
HTML reports of each restaurants
inspection rating which is really hard
to do comparisons across restaurants so
you know I web scraped that and got an
idea of which one of my favorite
restaurants were good on the inspection
rating and which ones were bad by the
way I wouldn't recommend doing that it's
not really that fun
now Yelp has it which is really a bummer
to me because now I can see which
restaurant I really liked for years that
is terrible but anyway maybe that's a
good thing so new data new insights
right real-time data is another
advantage so often in social sciences
and this may not be true in some places
in private industry but in social
sciences we have old data that is
informing proactive policies in real
time and the problem with that is that
we don't really know what's going on for
example with gentrification so you know
Amazon HQ to come into this area right
or a little bit close by and we're
trying to figure out like what are the
impacts going to be on the region the
most recent neighborhood level data we
have from the US census is an average of
2012 2013 2014 2015 and 2016 right so an
average of those five years is what we
know about people's income and changes
in you know local housing conditions you
know in a way that we that we really
trust from a great government statistic
allegiance II and so being able to
scrape data on rents or get data on
housing that in real time is a huge
advantage and we and we really take
advantage of it for informing policy
proactively and then last at save time
and money right because your alternative
to web scraping is manually doing it
yourself right which not only saves time
and money but also helps you retain good
people who don't want to go manually
through web sites clicking every day all
right so now I'm going to walk through a
few example projects and get to the
actionable tips so the three examples
I'm going to give are around
where we're informed a study of the
effects of criminal background checks on
people's access to jobs in Washington DC
the second is where we took a data set
on really granular data on jobs that's
super useful but no one uses in the
research community because it's hard to
access and centralize that in one big
data set and the third is you know this
this common organizational problem of
having lots of different systems
internally that have useful information
but they're all separate and so being
able to collect all of that information
within your organization and enable
people to find it easily is another
really good use case for web scraping so
this first example on criminal
background checks and access to jobs is
that you know when you when you get a
criminal background check what they're
looking for is what is not whether you
only had a conviction but whether you
have been brought to court and so this
is an important distinction because a
lot of cases we think don't actually end
in convictions but then don't get wiped
from the court records so you could get
rejected from a job not because you've
got a conviction on your record but
because you've been brought to court
you've been arrested for some reason
even if you are innocent and that case
just didn't get resolved in public
records right and this is a big problem
we think right but we don't know because
we don't have any active data on it it
turns out and so we went to the DC
Superior Court and said hey can we look
into this problem we'd love to you know
get access to that data and analyze it
and they said no you can't do that you
can't access the data we don't want to
allow you access that data and we said
man that sort of that that is a real
bummer because we think this is a really
interesting problem it could be a huge
problem for your residents but it turns
out the DC Superior Court had online an
online search tool to look through their
court records so you could look you
could put in your name and specifically
the first two letters of your last name
and the first letter of your first name
was all that was required and you could
look up your your court record and so by
iterating through all possible
combinations of your name you can now
extract all the million court records
that we might need in this case is a
little over a hundred thousand that we
might need to do this analysis and you
know I'll talk a little bit about why I
think that this was totally fine and
responsible and good later but just know
that the
a good example and I'll refer back to it
and we used it to determine that about
you know 68,000 people we're getting or
and this is not just the finding I'm
this is just some of description of how
we did it and we and the number of cases
collected which is about a hundred fifty
one thousand and we use that to say okay
there abouts we think we think there are
about 68,000 people of the population of
DC which is about 10% of the population
of DC that that have a record in this
database and only half of them have a
conviction so that's about 34,000 people
that could get caught in a criminal
background check even though they don't
have a conviction right and so this is a
way of providing evidence to a problem
to a real problem and and to put it in
the district's hands and say hey this is
a really important issue for you to
start cleaning up your data so that's
one example a more mundane example is
that this is a really useful data set if
you if you do any sort of economic
analysis most people haven't heard of it
it's called the longitudinal employer
dine employer household dynamics survey
and the US Census and basically it takes
state unemployment records and gives you
at a black level there 11 million blacks
in the US this is a really small
geography the number of jobs and the
number of people with a job in that
block and it also gives you for a cop
for every pair of blocks in the u.s. the
number of people that live in that block
and commute to the other one so it's a
really useful data set on like commuting
patterns where people live and work how
many jobs are you know job loss and gain
over time in very specific geographic
areas but they release it in seventy
five thousand five hundred and three
gzip CSV files all with the drop down
selection there there's no big single
dataset
right and this has been the biggest
barrier to social scientists actually
accessing this data we have people that
have been rerunning the wheel every time
in urban like just trying to access
these data over and over and taking like
a day to download and clean it and all
of that and so you know one great use of
web scraping is to write a Python
program in this case we did this in NATO
us we spun up a big server we write a
wrote a Python program and we downloaded
and sent those files to
[Music]
essential storage location and then spun
up a big data cluster using spark read
them in and wrote them out is one big
data file and so now everyone can access
this data in one place and it's really
easy for people to centrally you know
analyze and access the data quickly
whether it's via a single machine using
Python or whether they want to use PI
spark and a large cluster and analyze it
more efficiently so this is one example
of you know how do we get access there's
just great there's this barrier that the
government won't put down I mean we need
we need to get past it
the third is streamlining an internal
search so a couple of years ago I was
going around and talking about the great
benefits of web scraping to people at
urban and they said you know what my
real frustration is this is great you
know I I get it that I can find these
new data sources but like I can't find
where the budget template is in my
organization right I like I have to know
the right person in HR or in accounting
or in this in this department to be able
to find this resource and they tell me
oh yeah if you go to the intranet and
click on this one link or if you go to
this you know central resource and click
on this one link you'll you'll be able
to find it right and this is because in
our organization and many organizations
of people I've talked to there are
different systems that are built at
different times for different purposes
by different departments and different
people who may or may not still be in
the organization right and so one really
useful part of web scraping is you know
we have a system in box and we have our
you know visual directory system where
people sit in the building and they're
another system with their contact
information and their HR you know our HR
system and then we have our accounting
system where all of our projects
information resides right and so all
these systems are separate and some of
them are accessible via API and some of
them are old and not right and so Python
can do a great job of you know if for
those of you familiar with web scraping
you can use you know your your standard
request library to do to look at a
standard web page if that won't work you
can use selenium and you can you could
automate a web driver and look at
another web page if that does if that
doesn't work then maybe that system has
an API and you can interact with it and
Python could sort of do the job of
collecting all the information from the
system centralizing it in this case we
put it all in an Apache Solr instance
but you can put it in elasticsearch or
any sort
other searchable database and basically
enable you to put a search engine on top
of all that data on a regular basis so
you can automate that job put all the
data in one place allow it to be easily
searchable in this case we have our new
urban internal search as of two years
ago that helps people find things better
those are three like motivating examples
and there are many more obviously on web
scraping but you guys can think of I
just want to give you a flavor for how
we're using it at urban right so this
talk is about web scraping responsibly
so the first question I get is why web
scrape responsibly right what why
wouldn't I just web's great
I seriously get that question a lot
right because if you until you actually
know what the dangers are you really
don't know what you're getting into and
so you really just love to start with
horror stories as I feel like people
connected them more quickly and
hopefully it helps them learn from my
mistakes you know some people need to
make their own that's great I like to
try to lay them all out just in case
you'd like to learn from mine so you
know I haven't I have a few cases where
I've gotten our organization blocked
from accessing the censuses website for
a week it's a big problem for a social
and economic research organization not
to me have access to census data there
are other sites where you can get it it
turns out we have lots of friends so
ended up being ok I got in a bit of
trouble I've gotten a couple of legal
notices served to me threatening very
large fines which were larger than my
account balance right after grad school
I want to point out which was negative
so I was a little bit concerned with
those turned out after working with our
lawyers everything was talking to our
project representatives at those
organizations everything was fine
I have also gotten gotten organization
blocked from Google Scholar which is a
fairly useful site for those of you who
know it does help you search all
scientific publications it wasn't me who
actually got everyone blocked from
Google Scholar on AWS everyone's just
blocked on AWS from Google Scholar now
apparently a lot of people had that same
idea to scrape Google Scholar and Google
Scholar just blocks all AWS IPS right
now but you know you can get your
organisation block you can get in
trouble you can get in legal trouble
there are real fines that are so
stated with it I just talked to someone
a couple weeks ago just total
coincidence while putting together this
talk anonymous person I will not name at
the University of Chicago who is
scraping data from Florida State website
and I didn't know this but it turns out
in the state of Florida it is a felony
to block access or do so in some way to
a state website that is needed and this
this case was a court website that is
needed for access by the public and so
he was going through quite a bit of
legal trouble with the University and
the state of Florida trying to get his
name cleared for web scraping so I
mentioned these because I want to get
out to the seriousness of the actual
trouble you can get into both you know
blocking things for your organization
which isn't legal but just really
inconvenience people and make them mad
at you and then there's the legal aspect
and then there's another reason which is
that you should try to be a nice person
when you're doing these things now you
have this great power you should be
cognizant of some of the side effects
that you might have on the
organization's you're scraping your
organization and takes like that but I
hope this the scary part works the best
and anyway it has for the people that I
trained at urban and they haven't left
it so tools and tips so things I wish
people had told me that was the real
purpose of this talk I think some of
them you'll already know hopefully some
of them you'll take away and will be
interesting to you my hope is that you
take at least one of these away and say
huh I might use that on my next web
scraping project so here are some
responsible questions that I tell people
to ask and in fact I'll tell you later
that some of these are in our guidelines
specifically in our checklist before web
scraping so is my web scraper affecting
site latency right and site latency
means how long it takes when I make a
request to that web site when I type
that website's name into a browser when
I make a request in Python somehow with
URL libe with request with whatever I'm
using how long does it take for that
site to come back before I'm actually
actively scraping and when I'm actually
actively scraping it am I really
affecting that time that it takes to get
back right if it's if it was taking if
it was instantaneously delivering a
webpage to a user before I web scraped
it and now it takes it a minute that's a
problem right you are you're affecting
other people who are trying to access
that site you are affecting that
business you're affecting that public
organization wherever your script
from so is my web skipper affecting site
latency so if the site had my name and
email thing who I was right would I
still scrape from the website this
shouldn't stop you necessarily but it
should make you think right are you
actively if they know who you were would
you think would you think again so
another question is how can I minimize
the number and rate of request so this
goes back to the site latency right so
even if you don't think you're gonna be
affecting site latency still think a
little bit about you know how could I
make fewer requests do I really need it
in that amount of time do I need to
really make that many at the same time
things like that and sort of what are
the consequences if I block access for
my organization for me for my
organization for other folks this one's
pretty straightforward and then you know
what have others do whatever others I
know down to web scrape responsibly
write this talk is only a subset of all
the things that you can do to check to
scrape responsibly I'm going to show you
a couple other resources you can check
out I encourage you to share resources
with your organization's so that other
you can learn from others this is just a
subset of the things you can learn so is
my web scraper affecting site latency so
this is a tool called site monitor that
we've built it's public on github and
our public github account urban
institute so you can just Google Urban
Institute site monitor or you can take a
picture copy that site essentially what
it does is it's an add-on to the Pythons
request library that monitors the
latency of a website monitors how long
it takes that site to respond it does a
couple smart things one thing we does is
it has a burnin period you can set that
burnin period here it's 100 seconds that
burn in period essentially is a period
where you're just sending it you're
sending the site some random or just the
first 100 or first 700 whatever it is
and result and request to the site and
it's measuring the response time of the
site and it's saying okay you know
sometimes it's it's 100 milliseconds
sometimes it's a second that's not
really related to me because I'm doing
just some random non non difficult
requests to the site and then once that
burning period ends which is that
vertical line
Berdych vertical dashed line then it
actually starts scraping and
continuously measures that response
if after that burnin period that red
line is exceeded by our web scraper then
it'll say huh maybe I'm affecting the
weight and see the site maybe it could
be that other people are also I'm
scraping the site or that a lot of
people are hitting it all at once now so
I'm gonna take a step back so instead of
scraping with no delay
now I'm gonna scrape with a second delay
between every request and then if that's
still above the red line I'll say I'll
take another step back to two seconds
and then we take a step back and you can
set this number to any number you want
we set it to 30 after a 30 second delay
between requests we're pretty sure it's
not us anymore so we let the web scraper
run so this is just our way of
implementing it you can set these
constants in any way you want through
this package but it's one way of
measuring you can you can take a look at
the graphs or you can let the program do
it yourself of measuring the latency of
the site request as your web scraping
this works on top of requests so it
doesn't work on top of you know packages
you might use like selenium but I think
it's a you know we'd use requests
because it's the most common library we
use for web scraping yeah go ahead
yes we do I'm actually going to you are
a plant no you're not I'm sorry but yeah
that's actually two slides ahead so I
will get to that thank you for asking
so that site monitor the second is you
know what I scrape of if they still knew
it was me so the way we do this and the
way a lot of people recommend it this is
an our original idea is that in requests
you can send a header and that header
gets recorded by the web server and in
it you can add a user agent into your
dictionary that says hey I'm the Urban
Institute this is a research data
collector and here's my email in this
case one of our programmers Jeff levy
wrote this web scraper so Jeff Jeff
doesn't mind he's the one who wrote our
site monitor package as well so if you
really want to email him you can but you
know please don't without asking me
first so anyway so there's Urban
Institute site monitor there's Jeff
right he's like I'm being nice I'm
sending my email out to to this
organization in this case it's DC courts
as you can tell we have the host is DC
course gov and when we make this request
whether we post or get then they'll know
it's us and if they want to contact us
or they have any problems with it they
can get in touch how can I minimize the
burden on the site so a lot of people
the first was the first thing they do
when they're getting a when they're
using a web scraper and it takes hours
is man maybe I can paralyze this somehow
let me use multiprocessing
and I can you know use my local computer
that has four cores or eight cores I can
use an AWS computer that is 128 cores I
can I can really hit this site and
download it right this is how I got
black from census for a week by the way
I was like oh this is really smart I
know multi-processing I know requests I
can just paralyze this and I'll download
a hundred to a thousand the same time
right so the first thing to think about
is that is that really necessary can you
just wait a day can you wait an hour is
that you really need that data right now
the second is like you know census is
much as access much more in during the
day than at night and you know you
usually know your site and whether it
has that level of traffic during day or
night if not you can use site monitor to
your question and see whether or not
that level of traffic changes in a point
in time but typically we like to run
these things at night so
for the DC courts web scraper it took I
think it took almost a day and so we ran
it in two iterations one 12-hour at
night after people went home the next to
the next day right and so you can sort
of vary it however you want but you know
if you really don't need it that hour
that minute then I recommend doing a
single core not paralyzing and then
running it at night if you can and then
you know our multiple pages contained in
a single file so this is something that
a trick that I know a few people know
but I wish more people knew and this is
that you know when you're scraping a
website often you may have multiple
pages that all have different values on
them but it turns out when you look at
the underlying JavaScript of the site it
is pulling from one file one JSON file
one CSV file one TSV file whatever the
web developer put that format in and one
way to find out whether or not that site
is pulling data from a central file is I
mean I use Chrome a lot and you can use
this in other browsers but you go to the
developer console so that's right click
inspect for those you familiar the f12
shortcut on a keyboard you can go to
like help and go to your your console
and essentially in this console you'll
see a network tab that network tab once
you click it will every web request that
comes in will be recorded in that
network tab most often on newspapers
you'll see this as like click tracking
that they're doing on you you'll see
every request it makes to the
advertisers site to get more advertising
and write information about how you're
browsing that page you'll see all that
activity come on once you click that you
need to refresh the page first so it'll
start over and grab the first file and
grab all the files actually for that
website and you can see all the files
that are being grabbed by the website
normally there are like hundreds of
files so what I would do is click on the
xhr javascript tab lets you get you the
primary data files that are being pulled
by that website and so in this list this
is an example of an urban institute
interactive feature built by our web
team where we have lots of different
pages on a website and you can see in
that lower left if you can read it
there's CSV TSV files and a JSON file
and those are all the data that's
powering all those different pages so
instead of hitting the site hundreds of
times getting each data point from each
different page
you could go to the you know in go to
the console above the developer tools go
to the network tab refresh the page and
try to find those files and you can just
get the URL for them and download them
directly you don't even need to build a
web scraper right so that's that's a
that's a good trick for trying to figure
out do I really need to hit this page
that many times okay so now the you know
more serious stuff what are the
consequences of getting blocked I
already mentioned some of these fines
lawsuit jail I don't need to mention
them again organization or community
access gets blocked again don't need to
mention these again these can be big
negative consequences here's what Google
Scholar looks like from AWS this is the
message I got as well when I was trying
to automate it from organization we're
sorry but your computer may be sending
automated queries to protect our users
you are now blocked this is actually
less scary than getting a legal notice
but still not very fun and then what
others done to a web scrape responsibly
so I would look up the post called
ethics and web scraping on towards data
science I would look at how to crawl the
web politely on scraping hub there are
lots of these resources out there and
also share your code so you know
internally I can't share this externally
because there's some proprietary data in
this repo but we do have a lot of web
scraping projects that we do internally
and those projects we share throughout
our organizations so that other people
can just grab drag and drop our code you
know that way when they start with our
code or with our you know with our other
web scraping projects and start with the
basics then there are those time delays
built in right there are those calls to
site monitor already built in and so
they start with from a better point of
web scraping than just look goo going
online seeing how request works and
running their site without really
thinking through the consequences of web
scraping so we encourage you guys to
either set that up for your teams or
courage your team's to share their web
scripting code so then they'll turn to
the last part which is a little bit
boring but I find really important to
keep people out of trouble keep our
organization out of trouble from a
leadership standpoint is our
organizational policy so I have to put
this on here blah blah blah you have
time to read this and a lawyer that
should be obvious to you by now
how much trouble I got into all right so
approval for web scraping projects so
all projects are approved by the data
science team there aren't a ton so this
isn't a big a big lift on me or my team
and they should meet the guidelines
expressed in our organizational policy
so here are some good general guidelines
I can't share with you our web scraping
guidelines due to legal restrictions I
can give you the general outline of them
so I hope this is helpful
are you scraping a private company or a
public entity so there's a little bit of
the difference in the law here and again
I'm a lawyer
but having talked to many lawyers and
gotten in a lot of trouble I know
general guidelines for differences
private company or public entities
important public companies general
private entities generally have a
copyright on their webpages and that
copyright law is in a gray area right
now so it is not black and white as in
this is bad you will get in trouble
however they can send you threatening
legal notices that you may not you may
not know how to combat or that may drive
you into court which is not a good thing
there's been a couple cases one four
years ago with Craigslist in which
Craigslist won a case of a web scraper a
web scraping company that was trying to
collect all of their data and sell it
for commercial purposes there is also a
case last year with LinkedIn and which
LinkedIn lost at the lower court level
people who are saying LinkedIn data is
public we can leave though we have the
right to scrape it and so it's currently
a little bit of a gray area in terms of
whether or not this is legal or not but
you generally generally speaking public
entities have a mission to make data
public and therefore you don't you don't
you tend not to have that legal gray
area with public companies where you do
it with the private cop private
copyright law of private companies so
the first thing we usually do is you
know whether it's a public or private
entity just trying to contact the site
owner or the data owner first right just
get in touch with them often they'll
probably they'll be really nice and
provide it to you sometimes they'll be
like the DC courts and say no we don't
want to give you your data right but
oftentimes we've found that people will
just give us the data it's a little and
it's easier and just as fast as doing a
web scraper you know purpose commercial
or non-commercial most of the trouble
that people have gotten are reselling
the data or using web scraping as a tool
for making profit
for commercial purposes so these are
many of the big lawsuits that we've seen
you know I've talked to a lot of
reporters that have you know in data
journalism as this growing field that
are doing web scraping and you mostly
don't get in trouble for this you know a
lot of sting pieces on Airbnb for
example right where people scrape airbnb
x' data technically Airbnb could take
them to court I've talked to a bunch of
reporters when I was trying to figure
out like well is that legal what can we
do and they said you know we've never
gotten in trouble for them they know
that it's gonna look bad for them
publicly just to sue a reporter for the
data they're trying to they're trying to
be good citizens I'm not sure if that's
true or not but they're trying to be
good citizens and you know they don't
they they don't want to be seen in that
negative light so you know Purvis
commercial versus non-commercial makes a
big difference
volume and effect in site operations
obviously I think that should be effect
oh well
volume and effect on site operations is
important you want to make sure that
you're just minimizing volume as much as
possible so when we talk through people
people's projects for approval we say
you know what what ways you what steps
are you taking to minimize burden on the
site and then lastly always look at the
terms of services and the robots.txt
file of the site so just google the site
or site in site search Terms of Service
try to read through them if they
explicitly ban web scraping then you're
probably not being good citizen by web
scraping their site also similarly if
you go to the root domain of the website
so google.com slash robots.txt you know
urban oryx lash robots.txt whatever that
site is just take a look at that robots
that text file it'll list all the areas
of the site that they don't want
automated scrapers to collect from so
generally two useful places to search
terms of service robots.txt so when we
were doing the DC courts project we
looked at both the robots that text and
their Terms of Service
none of them forbid automated web
scraping DC courses of public domain is
a public organization we were collecting
it for non-commercial research purposes
and we use site monitor to ensure that
we were not negatively affecting their
volume right of their traffic going to
the site people could still search DC
Quartzsite it would still take them 30
seconds to get back a response from the
site site is really slow so we were not
materially affecting the response time
of do
kourt's so that's sort of the example I
give as you know we went through all of
these steps we tried to contact them
there but they said no they were a
public entity
it was non-commercial no effect on
operations check their Terms of Service
robots that text everything was fine we
said go we can go script them why these
guidelines so I just explained a little
bit about it you know public sites are
public domain but still check the Terms
of Service and robots that text to be
nice the largest legal cases primarily
concerned commercial scraping and
private websites that I've seen there
are a few minor exceptions to that but
this is where most of the trouble has
come negatively affecting access to a
site in my view is always bad so never
do it even even if you're outside of
Florida right I would still do I would
still say negative reflecting sites is
always bad it may not be a felony but
it's always bad and site owners will
sometimes provide data on a request if
you ask nicely so that's it for my talk
today we talked a lot about how we use
data science to elevate the debate
around social and economic policy on
data at urban it's our blog on medium we
talk about all kinds of cool stuff that
are not in this talk like how to set up
automated Big Data Services in AWS and
things like that so you can check us out
there i'm also on twitter at graham imac
and it's not because i have a mac it's
because graham i McDonald was taken and
that's my full name and so get in touch
with me I'll be happy to talk more talk
about other data science stuff but
otherwise thank you guys for coming I
appreciate it
okay yeah if anyone has any questions
[Music]
yeah that is that's a real tricky issue
so I will tell you with the DC courts
website we didn't originally think it
was sensitive data that we were
collecting we have in our organization
we have an internal review board process
for research which means we have to pass
everything through an internal review
board during that work we always
manually check the results of our
scraping data so looking at data as you
guys all know always the first line of
defense immediately we saw that on
accident some of the DC courts records
had addresses and Social Security
numbers and people publicly listed so we
went back to our IRB and said we didn't
think this an IRB issue it is an IRB
issue this is private and this is
private data so I think one thing - I
think that's a big issue one thing to do
is always to make sure you check your
data there a number of different ways to
do that we ended up writing a bunch of
different NLP and regular expression
parsers to ensure that all the data we
collected was immediately stripped out
and we notified DC courts but there's a
lot of different cases where that could
be true and I I think it was in this
case I I think checking the data
yourself is always the first line of
defense yep
mmm-hmm no that's a really good question
and I want to say that DC Police
Department was much better than DC
courts and was usually provided us with
data or we asked so that was very uh
kudos yeah see you know we heard I
didn't want to anyways there's not video
so I won't say anything but right so the
question was have you seen a push toward
open data because of web scraping yes
and no so I I do think that there is a
there is a point there where people have
been opening up data sets because you
know they've seen that there has been
some activity from like people like me
and people in code from DC and other
organizations that you know the science
DC and others I also think I know I
found this in my organization and in DC
as well where the biggest push has come
from within government sometimes where
the government really wants to know what
another agency has another agency won't
share it from them as you just said so I
think I think yes there is some push
from the web scrap from web scraping but
I think more so it's a push of oh I
didn't even know this other agency
within government had this data isn't
this awesome number one user of a lot of
these data pours is internal government
agencies in different departments so I
do think that's a part but not the
biggest part yet one more so it depends
on IR in related to the IRB process
depends on the type of data we're
collecting in this case yes we did as we
went through the IRB process so we
treated it in the same way depends on
the sensitivity the data we always read
a different IRB plan for a different
data so you know you have to have data
security David confidentiality we have
templates that we use and we start from
and largely yes thank you guys
you